Então, onde estamos? Bem, esta é
a aula de encerramento.
Quando começamos a nos reunir nesta
sala, há 3 meses e pouco,
o Yale Daily News publicou um
ensaio fotográfico
com neve por toda parte.
Em 13 de janeiro, quando o nosso
2º encontro começou,
o campus estava assim, assim,
assim, assim e assim...
Exatamente 3 meses depois,
o Yale Daily News
publicou outro ensaio... com esta foto,
esta, esta, esta, esta e esta.
É primavera.
E chegamos ao fim.
O que nós fizemos? Bem, nós
iniciamos com A República de Platão
e concluímos com A
República de Platão.
As estações mudaram.
Nós, de certa forma, fizemos uma
leitura complexa de uma das
obras mais fundamentais da
tradição filosófica ocidental.
Portanto, o que eu quero fazer hoje é
levá-los ao longo do curso
por 4 caminhos diferentes.
A 1ª coisa que eu quero
fazer é pensar em
como é que os objetivos do
curso foram atingidos.
Os objetivos de ajudar a pensar
sobre como o material
absorvido nesta aula se
relaciona com o material
absorvido em outra aula
e como isso se relaciona com os
pensamentos que você teve
na biblioteca ou as ideias que surgiram
em conversas durante o jantar.
O 2º caminho que eu quero tomar é
voltar à descrição inicial
do conteúdo programático dos 3
temas principais do curso
e apontar para o caminho em que o
entendimento de vocês
sobre os temas mudaram.
Vamos analisar a questão da
felicidade e prosperidade
como a encontramos nas obras de
Platão, Epicteto e Csikszentmihalyi.
Vamos analisar a questão da
moralidade como a encontramos
nas obras de Kant e Mill e, novamente,
no contexto dos casos do trolley.
E vamos refletir sobre as
questões da legitimidade social
e estruturas políticas tanto no
contexto de Rawls, Nozick e Hobbes
quanto no contexto do
Dilema do Prisioneiro.
Na 3ª parte da aula, eu quero
avançar por 3 temas
que eu encaro como os
unificadores do curso.
São 3 questões centrais, cada
uma das quais nos fornece
um modo de traçar um caminho
através das nossas leituras.
A 1ª, obviamente, é o tema
da alma multipartida.
A 2ª, o tema da sorte e controle.
E a 3ª, a questão da relação entre
o indivíduo e a sociedade.
E eu quero fechar a aula com o que,
para mim, são as 3 citações
centrais às quais eu vejo o
curso tendo sido organizado.
Uma de Epicteto, uma de
Aristóteles e uma,
que nós ainda não discutimos,
proveniente das páginas finais de
A República de Platão.
Então, vou começar recordando
o que o programa dizia
sobre os objetivos do curso.
O programa dizia que o curso tem 3
objetivos, o 1º deles era
"apresentá-los a uma série de
discussões filosóficas tradicionais
que abordam as questões profundas
sobre a condição humana
e ajudá-los a pensar de que forma
a metodologia da filosofia
fornece uma visão sobre elas".
E durante o nosso trajeto, vimos os
trabalhos de Platão, Aristóteles,
Epicteto, Hobbes, Kant,
Mill, Judy Thomson,
John Rawls e Robert Nozick.
E o que eu tentei oferecer em
cada um desses casos
foram as ferramentas para
que estes textos
tenham valia pelo resto da
vida de vocês.
Alguns dos exercícios envolviam
aprender a usar o material de apoio,
os índices ou o material
crítico anexado aos textos.
Assim, no caso de A
República de Platão
e do Ética a Nicômaco de Aristóteles,
usamos edições comentadas que
permitiam que vocês
aproveitassem ao máximo a
jornada por um texto antigo.
Em alguns dos casos, o problema era
ter a terminologia necessária
para dar sentido às palavras
técnicas utilizadas pelo autor.
E nós aprendemos a usar um
dicionário de filosofia
e outros recursos para nos
orientarmos nos textos
que pareciam técnicos.
Às vezes, a linguagem do
texto ficou pelo caminho.
Para muitos de vocês que leram
Hobbes no original do século 16,
foi mais difícil entender os
conceitos presentes.
E nós aprendemos a possibilidade
de usar a modernização
dos textos como forma de
compreendê-los.
E com os guias de leitura, as
perguntas de leitura,
as aulas e as discussões, o
objetivo foi proporcioná-los
as ferramentas de todo uma
vida, de modo que,
quando vocês virem a sua cópia
de A República de Platão
na estante, possam abri-la e
aprender por conta própria.
O 2º objetivo do curso
foi "apresentá-los
às discussões
relacionadas com esses
temas
a partir da perspectiva de outras
disciplinas acadêmicas,
particularmente da ciência e
psicologia cognitiva contemporânea,
e ajudá-los a pensar de que forma as
metodologias dessas disciplinas
fornecem conhecimentos sobre estas
questões fundamentais".
Portanto, iniciamos a nossa
discussão sobre o anel de Giges
analisando o trabalho empírico de
Daniel Batson inspirado
no desafio de Glauco na obra de Platão.
Quando analisamos Platão, Aristóteles e
Epicteto sobre a prosperidade,
fizemos isso à luz de Happiness
Hypothesis, de Jon Haidt,
que se debruçou sobre estas
questões históricas,
estudo após estudo, a partir da
tradição psicológica contemporânea.
Quando pensamos em como a
noção das partes da alma
se manifesta na nossa
linguagem contemporânea,
utilizamos a obra de Daniel
Kahneman e Amos Tversky,
as heurísticas e vieses, como uma
forma de tentar usar o nosso
vernáculo para refletir sobre as
percepções que fizeram parte
de todas as tradições do saber desde o
início da civilização humana.
Quando pensamos sobre o que
Platão quis dizer
com a alma harmoniosa e o que
Aristóteles entende pelo cultivo
do hábito permitindo que a
virtude se torne fácil,
nós refletimos sobre isso à luz da
noção de fluxo de Csikszentmihalyi
e consideramos as formas que
essa noção pode,
numa linguagem contemporânea,
ecoar as preocupações
dos autores antigos.
Quando pensamos sobre os custos
que uma alma desordenada poderia ter,
lemos o extraordinário trabalho de
Jonathan Shay, Achilles in Vietnam.
E refletimos sobre as formas que
a experiência de guerra
descrita em A Ilíada de Homero e a
experiência de guerra descrita
pelos veteranos ecoam uma experiência
humana comum em face da perda de um
certo tipo de estrutura.
Quando pensamos sobre as formas
que as atividades sociais
nos rodeiam – a tendência humana
inevitável em conformidade
com as exigências da autoridade...
quando pensamos sobre isso e como
pode afetar as pessoas,
fizemos isso à luz da obra
de Stanley Milgram.
Quando pensamos sobre como é que
podemos cultivar a virtude
em nós mesmos,
consideramos as
implicações
que isso pode ter para a parentalidade.
Quando refletimos sobre
como é que devemos
explicar as nossas respostas
para os casos do trolley,
consideramos se as bases neurais
– no que diz respeito
às ativações numa parte
específica do cérebro –
podem desempenhar algum
trabalho explicativo
para responder o que nos interessava.
Quando pensamos sobre como é
possível dar sentido a questões
da filosofia política e à
legitimidade do contrato social,
recorremos à noção da
teoria dos jogos
do Dilema do Prisioneiro e à ideia
da Tragédia dos Comuns.
Quando consideramos as formas em que
as estruturas sociais nos
afetam, analisamos a questão
das normas sociais e,
embora tivéssemos cortado caminho por
uma tradição intelectual,
refletimos sobre um mundo cheio de
outras tradições intelectuais
que mal tocamos.
Em todos esses casos, o
objetivo, como ocorre
com os textos filosóficos, era
fornecer as ferramentas e os recursos
para utilizar esse tipo de literatura
sem dificuldades no futuro.
Vocês fizeram um exercício dirigido
onde receberam um texto principal e
tiveram de encontrar os artigos que o
citavam e os artigos citados por ele.
Vocês foram convidados a
pegar um artigo
de uma publicação psicológica
empírica e descobrir
qual era a questão, que alternativas
estava sendo consideradas,
qual era a lógica do argumento, que
métodos estavam sendo utilizados,
os resultados e as
implicações encontrados.
E, então, vocês foram convidados a
executar um projeto experimental
próprio, após pensarem, no caso
do estudo de outra pessoa,
sobre como é um estudo.
O objetivo disso era não só
apresentá-los a uma extensa
faixa de literatura
psicológica, mas também
saber
que isso faz parte de um corpo
de recursos intelectuais
que está à sua disposição
pelo resto de sua vida.
O 3º objetivo do curso era
ajudá-los a pensar
sobre a sua própria educação
de forma sintética ao
"incentivá-los a serem sensíveis à
forma como as percepções
de um ou mais contextos
acadêmicos podem ser ecoados
ou iluminados pelas
percepções de outros".
Este curso é um estudo de caso,
um modelo, um exemplo,
de como é possível olhar
para um problema
a partir de múltiplas perspectivas.
E o exercício final, que pede
para vocês pensarem
sobre como é possível se
debruçar nas múltiplas
perspectivas sobre isso,
é uma tentativa de levá-los a pensar,
pelo resto do seu tempo em Yale
e pelo resto do seu tempo neste
planeta, de forma sintética.
Pensar sobre a variedade de cursos
e opções disponíveis
para vocês como coisas
interligadas na exploração
da questão fundamental que
define a experiência humana.
Então, este é o caminho
através do curso.
3 objetivos. 3 habilidades.
O caminho número 2 analisou 3
questões substantivas fundamentais.
O que pode ser dito, pelo
menos no contexto
da tradição ocidental (e talvez mais
além) sobre as condições em
que a felicidade autêntica e a
prosperidade verdadeira são possíveis.
A 2ª foi a questão de que
tipo de exigências a
moralidade faz para nós.
E a 3ª foi a questão da legitimidade
política e as estruturas sociais,
e as formas que elas nos afetam.
Então, se vocês olharem para o
programa, vocês vão ver
que o conjunto de questões
que visamos explorar
é o conjunto de questões que
nós realmente exploramos.
No contexto da felicidade e
prosperidade, nos perguntamos
como poderíamos pensar sobre a
sugestão de Platão de que a alma
humana tem várias partes pelo trabalho
contemporâneo da psicologia.
E nós exploramos não só a ideia de
Platão de que somos compostos
por razão, espírito e apetite,
mas também numerosas
manifestações do que hoje é
conhecida
como a tradição de
duplo processamento.
E vamos falar mais sobre isso
quando falarmos sobre os
temas de organização.
Nós questionamos como a discussão
de Aristóteles e Platão
sobre a importância da
amizade e do apego humano
é ecoada nas discussões recentes
sobre a felicidade e prosperidade.
E, infelizmente, por causa do
tempo, a aula foi abreviada.
Prometo que no próximo ano, quando eu
der essa aula com mais detalhes,
vocês estão convidados a
participar dela.
Nós nos perguntamos como as ideias
básicas do filósofo estóico
Epicteto se refletem nas práticas
terapêuticas modernas.
E reconhecemos que as ideias centrais
que ele tem – de reconhecer
o que está e não está sob
nosso controle e de perceber
que é possível ajustar os
desejos de tal modo
que o mundo seja mais cooperativo –
está no centro da prática
terapêutica moderna.
E, nesse contexto, lemos as
comoventes palavras
do almirante Stockdale, descrevendo
como as palavras de Epicteto
permitiram que ele sobrevivesse –
e inclusive prosperasse –
diante das condições degradantes
de um campo de prisioneiros
na Guerra do Vietnã.
Nós nos perguntamos como a
discussão de Aristóteles
sobre a fraqueza da vontade (akrasia)
se conecta com as discussões atuais
sobre a procrastinação e
como evitar isso.
E nós fomos apresentados a vários
recursos para estruturar
o nosso ambiente interno e externo,
de tal modo que os nossos
compromissos reflexivos possam ser
os que guiam a nossa prática, em vez
dos nossos hábitos destreinados.
E nos perguntamos como as
reflexões de Aristóteles
sobre o papel do hábito em cultivar
a virtude são refletidas
nos manuais de parentalidade
dos séculos 20 e 21.
Todas essas foram questões que
consideramos no contexto
da felicidade e prosperidade.
Todas essas foram palavras do
conteúdo programático que,
há 3 meses, espero eu,
significavam menos para vocês
do que significam agora.
Todas essas são questões
válidas para o resto da vida.
No contexto da nossa discussão sobre
a moralidade, nos perguntamos
quais são os princípios básicos das
teorias morais fundamentais
que compõem a tradição ocidental:
Ética das virtudes aristotélicas,
deontologia kantiana e
consequencialismo milliano.
Nós colocamos de lado, para os
propósitos deste curso,
uma 4ª vertente muito importante
que fundamenta a
moralidade na religião.
Porém, como resultado de ter
percorrido as questões,
temos as suposições do que essas
teorias fazem sobre a natureza
humana e o papel da moralidade,
as ferramentas para pensar
inclusive nas teorias morais
que não foram consideradas.
Nós analisamos as diferenças
nas teorias morais,
como elas enfatizam a
consequência, o ator ou o
caráter.
Analisamos as semelhanças
entre as teorias morais,
como elas enfatizam a importância
de superar um certo tipo
de excepcionalidade da 1ª pessoa.
Analisamos como essas teorias morais
lidam com a diferença entre a
intenção e o resultado.
E analisamos como essas teorias
morais fornecem e não fornecem
respostas diferentes a questões
normativas específicas.
Nós perguntamos a nós mesmos,
no contexto da discussão
sobre a moralidade,
como os recentes trabalhos
experimentais na intuição moral,
principalmente o problema do Trolley,
mas também casos relacionados,
relacionam-se com as discussões
filosóficas tradicionais
sobre a moralidade.
E como esse trabalho se conecta
com trabalhos
contemporâneos em
neurociência
e trabalhos relacionados em
psicologia cognitiva e social.
E por meio da descoberta de
que era muito difícil
chegar a explicações sistemáticas de
por que as nossas intuições
atuavam de uma forma num caso e
de outra em outros casos,
compreendemos o quão
desafiador é chegar
a uma teoria sistemática e, assim,
ganhamos mais conhecimento
para nossa questão original
sobre a estrutura
e complexidade da alma humana.
E nós refletimos, no contexto da nossa
discussão sobre a moralidade,
sobre a relação entre a
responsabilidade moral e sorte.
Reconhecendo, talvez do
jeito mais profundo,
que algumas coisas dependem de
nós e algumas coisas não.
E que a relação entre boas
intenções e bons resultados,
más intenções e resultados ruins,
não é tão estanque como
gostaríamos que fosse.
E nós nos perguntamos, nesse
contexto, quando a punição
poderia ser justificada e que papel
político e psicológico moral
ela desempenha como uma forma de pensar
sobre a contrapartida da questão moral.
E aprendemos, assim, que uma das
maneiras de pensar sobre
como as coisas deveriam ser quando
saem bem é pensar sobre
como as coisas deveriam ser
quando saem mal.
E, então, nós ganhamos mais uma
ferramenta ao refletir
sobre um conjunto de
questões fundamentais.
Como as perguntas sobre a
felicidade e prosperidade,
estas são questões para levar
para o resto da vida.
Na 3ª parte do curso, nós questionamos
o papel das estruturas sociais
ao permitir a prosperidade humana
e o comportamento moral.
E, na verdade, já havíamos antecipado essa
parte do curso na seção inicial.
Nós nos perguntamos o que as
experiências dos soldados gregos
na Guerra de Troia e dos
soldados norte-americanos
na Guerra do Vietnã nos dizem
sobre o papel da ordem social,
thamis, permitindo que os humanos
funcionem de forma eficaz.
E através disso e da discussão da
obra de Stanley Milgram,
tivemos o nosso 1º indício de
que muito do que somos
e como agimos é determinado não
apenas por coisas dentro de nós,
mas também pelas estruturas
comuns que nos rodeia.
E isso torna ainda mais premente
a série de questionamentos da
unidade final do curso.
Inspirada pela analogia
inicial de Platão de que,
para compreender a
estrutura da alma humana,
devemos entender a
estrutura da sociedade.
E para entender a
estrutura da sociedade,
devemos entender a
estrutura da alma humana.
E nós nos perguntamos
como é que o fato
de que somos, ao mesmo tempo,
desejosos de possuir objetos
que os outros possuem e desejosos de
poder estar numa posição
de segurança em relação
ao que nos prende,
descobrimos que havia uma
representação matemática,
a noção da teoria dos jogos do
Dilema do Prisioneiro,
que poderia iluminar a discussão
de Platão nas páginas
do Livro II de A República e a
discussão de Hobbes no Capítulo 13 de
O Leviatã de como as estruturas sociais
passam a existir de forma legítima.
Depois nos perguntamos,
analisando 2 textos centrais
da tradição filosófica política
ocidental do século 20,
como a obra de John Rawls e
Robert Nozick elucidam
a importância de que, em muitos casos,
parecem ser 2
considerações
concorrentes.
Por um lado, as considerações de
igualdade na obra de Rawls;
por outro, as de liberdade no
trabalho de Nozick,
na estruturação de uma
sociedade justa e legítima.
E nos perguntamos como os
trabalhos em psicologia social
e economia comportamental
podem lançar luz
sobre essas questões fundamentais.
E nos perguntamos, por último, na
nossa discussão sobre as normas
e estruturas sociais
básicas e a censura,
qual é o papel adequado para os meios
não-racionais de persuasão,
incluindo as influências culturais
de massa, como o cinema,
televisão e música, numa
sociedade democrática.
E percebemos, de uma forma estranha, que
as declarações de Dan Quayle
sobre Murphy Brown e os pontos de
vista sobre o videogame Madden
foram ecoando quase textualmente
as palavras de Platão do
Livro 10 de A República,
quando ele comenta sobre a
poesia e a censura.
Então, este é o nosso 2º
caminho através do curso.
Os 3 temas fundamentais
que identificamos,
as subquestões feitas em
relação a cada um deles,
bem como o estímulo a que
todos vocês continuem se
perguntando essas coisas.
Caminho número 3: 3 temas
de organização.
Como eu não quero que
desperdiçá-los nesta seção,
eu vou pedir para usarmos os clickers
pela última vez neste curso.
Portanto, vamos usá-los daqui a uns 4
slides a partir de agora e,
depois, em alguns slides posteriores.
Vocês se lembram que nós
começamos a nossa discussão
sobre as partes da alma com a
história de Platão sobre Leôncio.
Ele escreve em A República:
"Leôncio, filho de Aglaion,
ao voltar um dia do Pireu, seguia pela
parte exterior da muralha setentrional
quando viu cadáveres
estendidos perto do carrasco.
Ao mesmo tempo que um grande
desejo de observá-los,
sentiu repugnância e afastou-se".
Platão continua: "Durante alguns
instantes lutou consigo
e escondeu o rosto com as mãos.
Mas, por fim, dominado pelo
desejo, arregalou os olhos e,
correndo na direção dos
cadáveres, gritou:
'Aí tendes, maus gênios!
Fartai-vos deste belo espetáculo!'".
Talvez a gente não esteja
tentado por cadáveres.
Mas talvez a gente esteja tentado por
análogos contemporâneos.
E fomos apresentados, como uma
ferramenta de reflexão sobre isso,
à ideia de George Ainsle sobre o
desconto hiperbólico,
em que uma gratificação menor e
mais cedo – que de longe
não parece tão valiosa como a nossa
gratificação final – surge
como consequência da forma que nos
relacionamos com o valor/tempo
no momento da tomada de decisão.
Portanto, mesmo que o seu objetivo
seja passar o fim de semana
estudando e mesmo que, agora,
sob a perspectiva da
quinta-feira, a gratificação
maior
e mais tarde pareça a
melhor na sua mente,
existe o risco de você
se aproximar das curvas e...
cruzá-las, consumindo a gratificação
menor e mais cedo e abandonando
a maior e mais tarde.
Nós conversamos sobre isso,
onde mais de 50% de vocês
se comprometeram a desligar a
internet, seja completamente
ou restringindo o seu uso, de alguma
forma, no contexto da aula.
E eu perguntei no dia 25 de janeiro,
quando a neve ainda cobria o chão,
como vocês tinham se saído na tarefa.
E, nesse momento, daqueles
que se comprometeram
a algum tipo de restrição, 56% não
tinham se dissuado nem um pouquinho.
25% tinham se desviado
apenas 1 ou 2 vezes.
8% disseram que, algumas vezes sim,
mas que estavam tentando.
E 11% de vocês já tinham pulado fora.
Bom, a 1ª pergunta clicker vai
somente para aqueles
que fizeram algum tipo de compromisso:
qual é o resultado disso?
Se você tiver feito a promessa,
1) caso não tenha se
desviado do caminho;
2) algumas vezes, mas não
com muita frequência;
3) com bastante regularidade,
mas não o tempo todo;
ou 4) se, por exemplo, você
acabou de fechar o Facebook
e talvez queira participar da aula...
Então vamos ver, nos próximos
10 segundos, como são os
nossos números em comparação com
os do início do semestre.
Então, aqueles que fizeram a
promessa da internet,
30% se mantiveram firmes.
O resto de nós quer um
conselho desses 30%.
Por que isso funcionou? O
que vocês fizeram?
O que permitiu vocês seguirem
com os seus compromissos?
Outro 1/3 de vocês se desviou do
caminho algumas vezes,
mas não com frequência.
Mas cerca de 50%, apesar de terem
decidido fazer alguma coisa,
não foram capazes de seguir
com o compromisso.
Um dos objetivos deste curso é recordar
que tanto na tradição antiga
quanto na tradição moderna
de duplo processamento, existem
quadros teóricos para entender
por que nos encontramos
muitas vezes sem fazer
o que nos comprometemos a fazer e
como é que podemos estruturar
a nossa experiência e entorno de tal
forma que isso se torne mais fácil.
Então essa é uma das
formas que nós pensamos
sobre a questão das partes
da alma neste curso.
Nós também pensamos sobre
as partes da alma
como um desafio bastante profundo
para a metodologia em
qualquer disciplina.
Observamos, no contexto das
heurística e vieses,
que há casos em que somos
confrontados com escolhas
onde sabemos qual é a correta e
somos puxados para um caminho
por uma espécie de instinto e
para outro por outra coisa.
Por exemplo, nos casos de
frequência/probabilidade,
onde o seu objetivo é escolher a
caixa onde você tem a maior
probabilidade de tirar uma
bola vermelha...
E uma das caixas tem 1 bola
vermelha e 9 brancas
– 10% de chance –, enquanto a
outra caixa tem 8 bolas vermelhas
e 92 brancas – 8% de chance.
Sabemos que existe uma
tendência, sob carga cognitiva
ou não, em optar pela frequência
– a presença de 8 bolas
vermelhas aqui –
em vez da probabilidade –
o caso de 10% aqui.
Mas também sabemos que quando
somos puxados pela frequência
em vez da probabilidade, neste caso,
estamos cometendo um erro.
Em outros casos considerados,
não é tão fácil saber qual é a
resposta que endossamos reflexivamente.
Fomos apresentados a isso 2 vezes no
famoso problema da doença, de
Kahneman e Tversky.
A terrível doença atingiu 600
pessoas na sua cidade,
você é o prefeito e 2 opções de
tratamento estão disponíveis:
o plano A e o plano B.
Acontece que os planos são idênticos.
Mas o plano A é descrito
como um plano em
que 200 das 600 pessoas sobrevivem.
Enquanto o plano B, no 2º caso,
é descrito como um em
que 400 das 600 pessoas morrem.
E, também, com as determinações
probabilísticas deles.
Mas aqui estão os dados
fornecidos por vocês.
Aqueles que se encontraram com a
descrição verde da escolha
entre A e B preferiram o plano
A em 2/3 das vezes.
Aqueles que se encontraram com a
descrição azul da escolha entre A e B,
aquela que expressava 400 mortes em
vez de 200 vidas salvas,
mostraram exatamente uma
proporção inversa de respostas.
Mas em contraste ao caso de
frequência/probabilidade,
não está claro qual é o caminho
certo para enquadrar uma questão
de tomada de decisão sob
condições de certeza e incerteza.
Devemos pensar em quantos viverão?
Devemos pensar em quantos morrerão?
O enquadramento correto
não é tão óbvio.
E esse problema persistiu
outras várias vezes
no contexto das nossas
discussões sobre o trolley
– nos encontramos dando diferentes
tipos de respostas a casos
que foram teoricamente
desafiadores para distinguir.
Apenas 15% de vocês acharam que
era proibido desviar o trem
no caso da testemunha.
Ao passo que 78% acharam que
era proibido o trem
atingir o homem gordo nessa
versão do cenário.
Encontramos isso novamente no contexto
dos nossos casos de esquiva e blindagem.
Quase todos vocês
pensaram que estava bem,
se um urso estivesse vindo em sua
direção, sair do caminho dele,
mesmo que a consequência fosse
que o urso ferisse a pessoa de trás.
Mas quase nenhum de vocês
achou que era aceitável,
com um urso vindo em sua direção,
pegar a pessoa atrás de você e
colocá-la na sua frente como um escudo.
Será que essa diferença
segue algo real?
Ou são apenas respostas
diferentes dadas
pelas diferentes partes da alma?
Nós fomos confrontados com
isso repetidas vezes,
quando pensamos como
deveríamos usar, não a
razão,
mas o hábito como um método para
regular o comportamento.
Quando pensamos sobre o fluxo como um
estado de alma harmoniosa,
onde as partes da alma que
podem nos puxar
em distintas direções se juntam.
No contexto da função e da
justificação da punição,
onde nos perguntamos se há
qualquer justificação racional
para a retribuição ou se isso só
diz respeito a algo que,
pensando bem, nós não endossamos.
Nós nos perguntamos sobre a
relação entre as partes da alma
no contexto das nossas
discussões da semana passada
sobre as influências da ficção,
das normas e de outras formas
de persuasão não-racional na
formação de nossas vidas.
E nos perguntamos sobre isso
tacitamente todos os dias do curso
quando refletimos sobre a dificuldade,
ou talvez a impossibilidade
dada a nossa complexidade, de
conciliar as nossas respostas
intuitivas e reflexivas e atingir o que
Rawls chama de equilíbrio reflexivo.
Que seja difícil de reunir
princípios e prática,
que seja difícil de trazer a compreensão
sistemática aos casos particulares,
não significa que não
valha a pena tentar.
Mas o fato de nos frustarmos
várias vezes com isso pode,
por si só, trazer
lições filosóficas.
Esse é o tema do curso 1:
partes da alma.
Tema do curso 2: sorte,
controle e circunstâncias.
Nós fomos apresentados a um caso
paradigmático para contrastar
2 tipos de personagens.
Por um lado, o Alberto Sortudo
e o Celular Sortudo.
Um deles, uma pessoa que não fez
nada de errado, foi para casa
e não prejudicou ninguém.
O outro, uma pessoa que talvez
tenha feito algo arriscado,
foi para casa e não
prejudicou ninguém.
E contrastamos esses casos com os
seus homólogos de azar,
que a caminho de casa, seguindo
a mesma rota, acabaram,
não por esforço próprio,
prejudicando uma criança.
E quando eu perguntei sobre isso a
vocês, quase todos acharam
que o Alberto Sortudo não tinha feito
nada moralmente problemático.
97% responderam que ele não fez
algo moralmente condenável.
No caso do Azarado, mesmo que ele
tivesse causado um dano,
81% estavam dispostos a conceder a ele
a absolvição moral total.
Mas... e eu vou testá-los
novamente sobre isso...
quando eu perguntei se o
Celular Sortudo,
um sujeito que fez uma coisa um pouco
arriscada sem consequências nocivas,
tinha feito algo moralmente condenável,
78% de vocês disseram que sim.
Uma resposta mais ou menos,
embora não tão extrema,
na linha da resposta à pergunta
sobre se Celular Azarado
tinha feito algo moralmente
condenável – 92% disseram que sim.
Eu estou curiosa, porque estes
resultados me deixaram perplexa,
para saber se 6 semanas de
reflexão sobre a sorte moral
mudaram a opinião de vocês.
Portanto, o nosso velho
amigo Alberto Azarado
– aquele falando ao celular, que vai para
casa e não prejudica ninguém –,
assim como vocês, que assumem
riscos todos os dias,
riscos que podem causar consequências
das quais vocês se arrependeriam por
não terem tomado precauções.
Ao fazer isso, Oh senhores dos clickers,
vocês fazem algo
moralmente condenável?
E vamos ver como estes números saem.
Assim, em contraste com a
avaliação anterior,
em que, no caso do Alberto Azarado,
81% de vocês acharam que ele fez
algo moralmente condenável,
agora temos apenas 36%.
Por quê? Eu não sei.
Mas vale a pena pensar sobre
por que isso aconteceu.
Vamos comparar isso com o caso
do Celular Sortudo...
Desculpem, eu acabei de fazer a
pergunta sobre o Alberto Sortudo
articulando a questão do
Celular Sortudo.
Os dados estão distorcidos e eu vou
ter de pular esta questão.
Por isso, eu peço que vocês
se perguntem em casa
o que pensam sobre esses casos.
Como eu me equivoquei nas coisas, preciso
avançar para o próximo ponto.
Embora sejam ótimos números.
A pergunta que está em pauta continuará a
ser um tópico para futuras pesquisas.
Tudo bem... eu tenho apenas 6 minutos,
então eu quero comentar rapidamente...
houve um quebra-cabeça fundamental e
recorrente que encaramos nesta classe.
Determinar o que está e o que não está
sob nosso controle em relação
à nossa atribuição de louvor e culpa em
casos de resultado não-intencional.
Definir o papel do que está e não
está sob nosso controle
nas nossas próprias reações
internas para os eventos.
No nosso reconhecimento do grau
em que estamos moldados
pelas circunstâncias sociais, como
tratado por Aristóteles,
Doris, Shay, Milgram e os
estudos "OEIRD",
Sunstein e Platão, e explorar como
isso deve ser normativamente
levado em conta, política e moralmente.
Esse é o tema número 2.
Tema número 3: o
indivíduo e a sociedade.
Às vezes as coisas que são OK
para um indivíduo fazer,
podem se tornar problemáticas
quando feitas por muitos.
Não há nenhum problema em
poluir se a maior parte
do meio ambiente permanecer limpo.
Há um grande problema em
poluir se o resultado for
a falta de ar para todo mundo.
Não há quebra dos padrões se um
de nós decidir dar dinheiro
para alguém cujo trabalho admiramos.
Mas, como Nozick aponta, há uma
perturbação dos padrões
se muitos tiverem a mesma atitude.
Os custos desses tipos de padrões podem
ser mínimos em certos contextos,
mas em outros essas diferenças
podem causar uma perda
da nossa instituição
democrática fundamental.
Portanto, no contexto da nossa
discussão sobre a relação
entre o indivíduo e a
sociedade, fomos ensinados,
tanto no contexto da seção
de filosofia moral
quanto no da seção de
filosofia política,
que se queremos tornar reais
os nossos compromissos
para viver como membros de uma
comunidade é preciso ter
uma maneira vívida de
representar diante de nós mesmos
que somos apenas um entre muitos.
E temos 2 belas articulações disso.
Uma formulação do imperativo
categórico de Kant
que o meu desejo pode servir de base
para as ações intencionais
só se eu puder, simultaneamente, de forma
coerente, querer que os outros,
em circunstâncias
semelhantes, ajam da mesma
forma
que eu estou escolhendo agir.
E a articulação de Rawls sobre
o véu da ignorância
como uma forma de pensar sobre o
que a justiça exige.
O bonito nessas articulações é
que elas são uma tentativa
de trazer à tona algo que a razão nos
havia trazido numa formulação
que podemos utilizar de forma intuitiva.
As tentativas de nos oferecer formas
vívidas para permanecermos comprometidos
com o que todos vocês, ou quase
todos vocês nesta turma,
sugerem que estão comprometidos.
Que é a educação, a moradia, a saúde
e a distribuição de recursos,
para uma distribuição um pouco
mais igualitária dos bens do
que poderia ser se não pensássemos
sobre a nossa experiência
a partir da perspectiva da
comunidade como um todo.
E eu vou pular 3 slides
– apesar de colocá-los na
internet para vocês –
sobre um estudo recente mostrando
que as respostas de vocês
nestes casos não foram uma exceção.
Eu quero finalizar
destacando 3 citações que,
para mim, simbolizaram o curso.
A 1ª citação é de Epicteto, que diz
que quando estamos prestes a se
deparar com uma experiência
que nos preocupa, podemos encontrar
desagradável ter de pensar
como ela seria e nos
prepararmos para ela.
O que perturba as pessoas, diz
Epicteto, não são as coisas,
mas os julgamentos sobre elas.
A 2ª citação é de Aristóteles,
que eu expus em quase todas as
aulas no início do curso.
Que nós aprendemos um ofício
praticando-o e que cultivamos as virtudes
agindo como se já fôssemos virtuosos.
Se existe algo que você
deseja se tornar,
aja como se isso fosse o
que você já é.
E eu encerro com, talvez, a parte mais
bonita de A República de Platão,
o Mito de Er, em que Platão
descreve a história
de um grupo de almas desencarnadas
que as pessoas prestes a nascer
estão autorizadas a selecionar.
Elas são oferecidas a modelos de vida e se
pede para escolherem uma entre elas.
E é no contexto de escolher que
tipo de vida você quer viver
que as questões deste curso se
tornam mais premente.
Pensem sobre como os tipos de
coisas que mencionamos,
de janeiro até agora,
determinam a vida virtuosa.
"[...] confrontando todas
estas considerações
e não perdendo de vista a
natureza da alma,
possa escolher entre uma vida
má e uma vida boa,
... chamando má à que possa
tomar a alma mais injusta
e boa à que a torne mais justa."
E lembrem-se que na página de
encerramento de A República de Platão,
Ulisses, o grande herói, célebre por
suas façanhas na Guerra de Troia,
reconhece que a vida que lhe
permitirá prosperar mais
é a vida pacata de um indivíduo
privado que faz o seu trabalho,
se concentra nas coisas à sua
volta, trazendo, de tal forma,
alegria para quem está perto e,
assim, para si mesmo.
E com as palavras iniciais e finais
de A República de Platão,
eu agradeço a todos vocês pelo
semestre maravilhoso.
[APLAUSOS]